et sur ce plateau michel fize sociologue
bonjour vous êtes auteur de nombreux
ouvrages notamment l'école à la ramasse
éditions l'archipel une insurrection
populaire en cours aux éditions amazon
du côté sociologique on parle d'une
mobilisation qui se perpétue dans la rue
on le voit aujourd'hui on l'a vu
vendredi dernier vendredi dernier il y
avait 2 149 mille 1,3 million de
personnes selon les différentes sources
à à quoi s'attendre aujourd'hui en terme
de participation
alors je pense encore une fois qu'il
faut rappeler que la colère est profonde
parce que les dégradations de devis sont
aujourd'hui terrible pour un grand
nombre en grand nombre de français donc
on peut penser que ce mouvement va
perdurer sous cette forme
bon avec peut-être évidemment des
mobilisations moins grande à certains
moments mais je dirais comme je le
disais pour les gilet jaune
il y encore un an il ya une
détermination qui est qui et qui est
forte parce que bon les gens voient bien
que leur pouvoir d'achat ne s'améliore
pas et qu'en plus on est en train de
pénaliser leur pouvoir d'achat futur
quand ils seront retraités donc tout ça
est inacceptable je rajouterais une
chose parce que c'est un critère qu'on
ne prend pas en compte on dit
effectivement parce que l'espérance de
vie est plus importante
on va allonger évidemment le temps le
temps d'activité mais on oublie un
paramètre sait que l'espérance de vie
n'est pas la même selon les catégories
sociales
on meurt plus tôt quand on appartient
aux catégories populaires et on meurt
plus tard quand on appartient aux
catégories supérieures
donc il faudrait peut-être faire partie
plutôt aussi ce qui pour le moment
meurent plus tôt dans ce pays pour
revenir son point de vue sociologique
vous êtes sociologue
on le dit on le voit donc la
mobilisation perdure dans la rue mais
d'un autre côté on a l'impression que la
grève s'essouffle en tous les cas dans
les faits aujourd'hui
le trafic et à la normale à la ratp à la
sncf comment expliquer ce paradoxe savez
bon l'essoufflement du mandé gilet jaune
a duré un peu plus d'un an
je crois qu'il est encore trop tôt pour
parler d'essoufflement ou de baroud
d'honneur 1 comme il s'est dit la
dernière la dernière fois je crois que
je crois qu'en réalité il y a tellement
de catégories sociales aujourd'hui qui
se trouvent en difficulté 1
quelques unes ont été cités dans les
différents reportages que vous avez vu
les pompiers qui sont descendus bon les
avocats qui sont toujours présents
on pourrait imaginer un retour des
anciennes justement vous parlez des
pompiers ils ont eu gain de cause sur
une partie nos revendications et hier
puisqu'ils ont une augmentation de leur
prime de feu + 6 % pour passer à 25% et
demandait à 28 pour cent mais ils ont
quand même certains gain de cause leur
retraite qui va être resté à 55 ans
est-ce que du coup ça veut dire que il
faut manifester parfois même violemment
il ya en a vu des images assez violente
pour pouvoir obtenir gain de cause et
savait bon les intéressés le disent eux
même si on ne t'a pas du poing sur la
table
si on ne se manifeste pas d'une manière
bruyante quelquefois voire violente
on n'est pas on n'est pas entendu 1 les
pompiers rappelé qu' il négocié entre
guillemets depuis le mois d'octobre
dernier et que rien n'était arrivé en
termes de propositions
donc il a fallu cette journée évidemment
un peu dur hier en terme de
de présence dans les défilés bons pour
arriver à obtenir obtenir satisfaction
ce qui monte quand même que derrière la
question de la retraite il y a toujours
et depuis le départ du mouvement des
jeunes ya toujours la question du
pouvoir d'achat le pouvoir d'achat il
est dégradé les professions sont pour
beaucoup sinistrés de ce point de vue là
alors quand on annonce par exemple la
hausse de effectivement ou la baisse de
l'impôt sur le revenu et qu'on annonce
300 euros de gain pour la tranche la
plus faible 11 % aujourd'hui
quand on calcule bien ça fait à peine 30
euros par mois
c'est un petit filet à provisions vous
rendez compte d'un pouvoir d'achat
vous parlez de nombreuses professions
aujourd'hui on a plusieurs
plusieurs corps professionnels qui sont
réunies on l'a vu notamment au micro de
guimard aussi il ya des des avocats il
ya des enseignants il ya des cheminots
il ya des éboueurs il ya beaucoup de
professions
mais
et que penser finalement deux de la
suite de cette mobilisation
pour le moment on est dans une sorte de
logique de juxtaposition de l'expression
des mécontentements
on a un peu l'impression c'est une
catégorie après l'autre et cette
convergence que les syndicats notamment
de salariés appellent bon n'est toujours
pas réalisée
mais elle ne se décrète pas pas plus que
beaucoup d'autres choses à dire dernière
question rapidement menées de par les
deux syndicats aujourd'hui donc la cgt
fo en tête il ya la fsu et solidaires
des organisations de la jeunesse
la cfdt n'est plus là depuis un petit
moment mais laurent berger son patron a
évoqué des chiffres contestables au
niveau de l'étude de l'impact basée sur
un équilibre à 65 ans est ce que vous
pensez que la cgt la cfdt puisse revenir
dans la rue prochainement je pense que
le cfdt peut avoir logiquement
l'impression d'avoir été un peu berner 1
d'abord parce que le fameux ajd
équilibre dont elle ne voulait pas il
figure quand même toujours sur le projet
de loi
aujourd'hui la convention du financement
va intervenir à un moment donné où les
juges sont déjà présentés comme étant
comme étant fait donc jusqu'à quand la
cfdt va effectivement accepté de jouer
un jeu où elle apparaît un peu comme la
dupe d'aider des échanges c'est le mot
de la fin merci michel fize d'avoir à
répondre à une question sera bien sûr
que vous êtes sociologue spécialiste des
mouvements populaires